worst city you performed in in why worst
city I can answer that for
him I can answer that for you shreport
Louisiana oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and for this reason and this reason only
for some reason there is some tradition
with the local law enforcement to tase
the local Main Event after the Saturday
night late
show so have you has anybody in here
ever been to
shrip do you know down downtown there
across from the
casino there's that like three or four
block radius of just bars and
restaurants right and I don't know if
it's it's the same now but down there
they had a separate police force that
wore orange shirts that police that that
police just that area that only answered
to the r the orange
shirts so they listen if you ever heard
of a guy named Josh Brolin getting tazed
in sheveport same group of cops so on
Thursday night I show up and the guy
goes to me he goes hey and I go yeah and
he goes hey just so you know we tase the
headline comic on Saturday and I was
like
yeah because of course that's not real
right and Friday night they come by and
they're like you ready I'm
like and the one of the weight staff
walked by and was like don't
laugh and I said why and she goes it
only makes it
worse sounds like she's in on it oh dude
they all BL so then Saturday night came
and I got my paycheck and the manager
goes so you ready I go for what she was
like she was like you know you're
getting tased they're waiting outside
the
office I was like no they're police
officers and she was like
yeah so I walk out and there's three of
them two with tasers and one with a
camera with a camera and so I was like
are you guys serious and they're like
yeah yeah just tase everybody just you
know like as a welcome to Shri Port I'm
like I'm not I'm not sure you know the
meaning of that word um [__] that and he
was like you can either get the gun you
know that one the and like that or we
can give you one in each leg cuz they
had the and I said I'll take the one on
each leg and I go hey but that guy's
gonna have to put down the camera and he
was like why I said well I can't fall
man this is this is look at this is
where I make my money dude I can't be
falling face first
and he was like no we'll hold you one
arm and and I go okay and they just
[__] and has anyone been tased in
here
before yeah that's not a huge surprise
both of you not a big surprise at all no
not this
[__] uh yeah and so it was not
pleasant um I will tell you though like
oddly I felt it in three places
my leg my leg and directly on my
butthole it why I don't know if that is
that channels the electricity or
whatever if that skins tougher or
thicker I don't know but it was
like yeah it was that's uh unfortunate
yeah yeah so uh streetport Louisiana uh
for sure